welcome Ramadan with certain sayings
Ramadan Mubarak some people say it's a b
and others say it's a Sunnah what is
your uh ruling on
this to welcome month is good
alhamdulillah and our Prophet always
informed the other people about this
month and as I mentioned earlier that
our beloved Prophet wasallam it's
mentioned in musnad Ahmed R number two
page number
230 Hadith number 7148 which is also
repeated it is mentioned in sunai
chapter number 5 Hadith number 21106
that our beloved Prophet sallallah Al
wasallam used to always tell the people
when the month used to approach when it
used to come the prophet to tell the
people in advance oh
people the Blessed month of Ramadan is
approaching
you and Allah subhana wa tala has
ordained for you that you fast in this
month so the prophet used to welcome
this month he used to wish other people
the same way today if he wish as the
prophet said the Blessed month is
approaching if someone says Ramadan
Mubarak this Ramadan Mubarak is more
often said in the Indian
subcontinent by the Indians by the
pakistanis because this word Mubarak
though Bara is an Arabic word Bara means
blessing and it is nothing but blessed
month but when the Indians and
pakistanis when they use the word mu it
is more of a sort of
congratulation when someone passes
examination they sayak in U which you D
from the Arabic word bar so when Ramadan
comes they wish Ramadan Mubarak saying
that it is the Blessed month or a sort
of
congratulating and wishing each other
that the Blessed month is approaching so
according to me it's not a b you can
welcome the month it's a good thing that
you're calling this month a blessed
month and you're informing other people
reminding them that in this month is lot
of blessing so according to me it's not
ABA but how you wish the words you
choose that is muah that's optional like
in Indian subcontinent we use the word
Ramadan Mubarak in the Gulf countries
they use Ramadan Kim so all these words
are good the holy month or the Blessed
month or the month of forgiveness so the
choice of words is yours but the prophet
mall wasallam he used to say to the
people that oh people the Blessed month
of Ramadan is approaching so I feel
people should wish other and they should
remind each other about this blessed
month mashallah